as the delta sigma phi beta kappa
variant of the wuflu reportedly rages
around the country democrat states and
counties are turning the tyranny up to
11. even some prominent republicans are
joining the calls to get you masked
faxed and locked back in your home
including the governator who does not
think very highly of your freedom
there is a virus here it kills people
and the only way we prevented this is to
get vaccinated to wear masks to do
social distancing washing your hands all
the time and not just to think about
well my freedom is being kind of
disturbed here no
screw your freedom because with freedom
comes obligations and uh and had
responsibilities we cannot just say i
have the right to do x y and z when you
affect other people
quite an about face we've gone from
don't be a girly man to wear your mask
and hide in your home my
schwarzenegger's not that good believe
it or not schwarzenegger is actually
moderate in his views compared to the
rest of the world where some uh
different countries health officers are
calling for an end to conversation in
the name of saving lives meanwhile
federal judge tries to lock up capitol
riders and throw away the key even as
minnesota democrats celebrate the george
floyd arsonists lots of people are going
along with these new rules in the hopes
of getting back to normal how long
before they all realize this is the new
normal
arnold schwarzenegger
[Music]
sort of has a point he sort of could
have a point let's put it that way when
he says that with freedom comes
responsibility of course nobody denies
that with rights come duties and
obligations yeah of course
does that mean that because there is a
cough that's been going around the world
we need to
lock people in their homes out of their
businesses out of their churches take
away their civil liberties and shut down
travel shut down christmas shut them
thanksgiving shut down conversation
among your neighbors i don't think so
that seems to be a step too far but that
that is the line he is articulating and
don't forget arnold schwarzenegger is a
moderate republican he's not even a far
leftist and oral schwarzenegger is
articulating the excuse that the ruling
class has relied on since the beginning
of this this
lockdown namely
in the name of public health we can do
whatever we want
i'm so glad you liked that video i hope
you check out the whole episode it's
available here on youtube but more
importantly than that
it's available at apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher wherever you get
your podcast subscribe to the michael
knowles show i really really appreciate
it sort of helps us circumvent some of
the big tech sensors out there i'll
leave a five-star review if you wouldn't
mind we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you